and now I'm very pleased to introduce
tonight's speaker Adam Cohen is a New
York Times bestselling author and a
lecturer at Yale Law School he has
formerly served as a member of the New
York Times editorial board and was a
senior writer for Time magazine where he
also has a weekly la column before
entering journalism Cohen was an
education reform lawyer and was a staff
attorney for the American Civil
Liberties Union a graduate of Harvard
Law School he was president of vol 100
of the Harvard Law Review and his
previous books include nothing to fear
FDR's inner circle in the hundred days
that created modern America his latest
book imbeciles chronicles the Supreme
Court's decision in 1927 to allow
Virginia to sterilize a young woman for
eugenic reasons the New Republic calls
imbeciles an important new book that
takes us back to a rarely remembered era
of our history reminding us that Adolf
Hitler regarded American eugenic law as
an inspiration Cohen's narrative of the
legal case that enshrined these
practices as a page-turner and the story
it tells is deeply almost physically
infuriating we're very pleased to bring
the conversation to Harvard bookstore
tonight please join me in welcoming Adam
color thank you thank you very much
it's a pleasure to be here I'd like to
thank Harvard bookstore for hosting a
wonderful bookstore that I used to spend
a lot of time in when I was here in a
previous life and thank you all for
turning out including some old friends
here at a book party in New York
recently and the invitation that went
out automatically as these things are
now I said to the top imbeciles book
party and some of my friends objected
about what it would mean if they
attended so I think this was also billed
as imbeciles book talk so I want to
congratulate you all for coming and not
being afraid so this feels for me like a
homecoming we're about equidistant
between my freshman dorm which is if you
want two feet that way and college
newspaper a little closer where I spend
a lot of time and it's it feels great to
be back um so in 1927 the Supreme Court
was asked to do
side a simple question should Virginia
be allowed to sterilize Carrie buck a 20
year old inmate of the state colony for
epileptics and feeble-minded who had
falsely been declared to be
feeble-minded in an 8 to 1 decision
written by justice Oliver Wendell Holmes
the court ruled that no part of the
Constitution not equal protection not to
process not the right to bodily
integrity protected carry buck from
being sterilized against her will
plenty terrible but the court did even
more it also strongly endorsed the
eugenics movement and issued a clarion
call to the nation to sterilize more
unfit people just as Holmes wrote that
the nation had to sterilize those who
SAP the strength of the state to prevent
our being swamped with incompetence in
words that could have been torn from the
pages of a eugenics pamphlet Holmes
declared it is better for all the world
if instead of waiting to execute
degenerate offspring for crime or let
them starve for their imbecility society
can prevent those who are manifestly
unfit from continuing their kind then
Holmes went on to include in the
decision one of the most brutal
aphorisms in American jurisprudence
Holmes the Harvard educated scion of
several of Boston's finest families said
of Kerry buck her mother and her young
daughter
three generations of imbeciles are
enough when legal scholars rank the
Supreme Court's worst decisions the
competition is considerable there was
the Dred Scott case in which the court
ruled that an enslaved man had no right
to sue in court for his freedom
there was Plessy vs. Ferguson in which
the court upheld Louisiana's law
segregating railroad cars by race and
there was Korematsu versus the United
States which the court upheld the
internment of japanese-americans during
World War two there will always be
differences of opinions over which of
these rulings should be on a list of the
worst decisions and how they should be
ranked but there can be no doubt that
buck V Bell must have a prominent place
in its aftermath not only was Carrie
buck sterilized against her will but in
the end as many as 70,000 Americans were
sterilized many of the victims were like
Carrie perfectly normal both mentally
and physically and they desperately
wanted to have children
buck fie bells reach extended beyond the
United States the Nazi Party which was
on the rise in Germany used America as a
model for its own eugenics
program the Supreme Court's ruling
influenced Germany's genetic health
courts which ordered some 375,000
eugenic sterilization in fact at the
Nuremberg trials at the end of World War
two Nazis responsible for the
sterilizations cited buck vs. Bell in
their defense while many of the courts
worst decisions are now central parts of
American history buck V Bell is not well
remembered today even in law school
constitutional law courses it is rarely
discussed or mentioned only in passing
the leading American constitutional law
treatise which weighs in at over 1,700
pages devotes just half a sentence and a
footnote to the case I'd like to talk a
little bit about Bucky Bell a case that
became ever more interesting the more I
learned about it and I'd like to offer a
few thoughts about why it remains
important and then I'd like to open this
up and get a conversation going um the
United States in the 1920s was caught up
in a mania the drive to use newly
discovered hereditary science to perfect
humanity modern eugenics which had
emerged in England among followers of
Charles Darwin crossed the Atlantic and
became a full-fledged intellectual craze
the United States suddenly had a new
enemy bad germ plasm and those who
carried it the unfit the genesis warns
threatened warned threatened to bring
down not only the nation but the whole
human race America's leading citizens
led the charge to save humanity john d
rockefeller jr. Alexander Graham Bell
and former President Theodore Roosevelt
who took to the pages of a national
magazine to insist that the unfit must
be forbidden to leave offspring behind
them prominent scientists form eugenic
organizations with names like the
committee to study and to report on the
best practical means of cutting off the
defective gene plasm of in the American
population in big cities and small towns
eugenics was the intellectual issue of
the day Women's Clubs invited lectures
to speak on the subject of arranging
eugenic marriages clergymen competed in
national eugenic sermon contests
organized on topics like religion and
eugenics does the church have any
responsibility for improving the human
stock best-selling books and magazines
explain the concept of quote race
betterment to an eager public the
inspiring the wonderful message of the
new heredity
cosmopolitan explained was that it
offered the promise of preventing once
and for all the birth of the diseased or
crippled or depraved conferences were
held the American Museum of Natural
History in New York hosted the second
International eugenics congress a truly
terrible gathering and the US State
Department sent out the invitations
universities were quick to embrace
eugenics and give it their intellectual
imprimatur eugenics was taught at over
300 universities and colleges including
right here Harvard Columbia Berkeley and
Cornell the driving force behind the
eugenics movement of the 1920s was
historians suggest the collective fears
of the anglo-saxon upper and middle
classes about a changing America record
levels of immigration were transforming
the nation's ethnic and religious makeup
and with increased industrialization and
urbanization community and family ties
were fraying these anxieties were being
redirected and expressed in the form of
fears about the unfit the eugenics
movement offered two solutions one for
the threat from without and one for the
danger from within the answer to the
foreign threat was new immigration laws
to limit the number of Italians Jews and
other non Northern Europeans admitted to
the country the eugenicist claimed that
these groups had inordinately high
levels of physical and mental hereditary
defects that were degrading America's
gene pool among other things they
claimed based on intelligence testing
that between 40 and 50 percent of Jewish
immigrants arriving at Ellis Island were
mentally defective Congress held
hearings at which new genesis explained
various nationalities biological
deficiencies acting on these eugenic
arguments Congress adopted the
Immigration Act of 1924 which invited in
more immigrants from Northern Europe and
closed the door to Southern and Eastern
Europeans the harm that this immigration
law did was immense most of all to the
Jews of Eastern Europe who would soon be
trying to flee Nazi Germany's genocide
or regime and would find the door shut
we now know that in the 1940s otto frank
wrote repeatedly and desperately for
visas for his wife and his daughters
Margot and Anne but he was turned down
because of the 1924 act so when we think
about Anne Frank it's true that she died
in a concentration camp because the
Nazis thought Jews were racially
inferior but she also died there
the US Congress believed the same thing
in addition to immigration limits to
deal with the ex the external threat the
eugenicist worked to address the
internal threat through a series of laws
designed to prevent the quote unfit from
reproducing they began in Connecticut in
1895 with laws prohibiting various kinds
of people deemed to be hereditarily
unworthy for marrying but New Genesis
worried that the unfit would then just
reproduce out of wedlock next they
promoted segregation as they called it
placing quote defective people in state
institutions during their reproductive
years to prevent them from passing their
law their flaws on to a new generation
but holding that many people in
institutions for so long was expensive
finally the eugenicist turned to
sterilization which was completely
effective and could be carried out on a
mass scale inexpensively starting with
Indiana and 1907 states adopted
legislation authorizing forced
sterilization of people judged to have
hereditary defects they called for
sterilizing anyone with quote defective
traits such as epilepsy criminality
alcoholism or dependency in other word
for poverty their greatest target
however was the feeble-minded
a loose tech designation that included
people who were mentally challenged
women considered to be excessively
interested in sex and various other
categories of individuals who offended
the middle-class sensibilities of judges
and social workers fears of the tide of
feeble mindedness as it was called rose
to panic levels a leading psychologist
published an influential study arguing
that feeble-mindedness quote underlies
all of our social problems including
crime poverty and prostitution the
eugenic sterilization movements most
prominent leader insisted that to remove
the quote worthless 1/10 of the nation
15 million people would have to go under
the knife Virginia was late to adopt
eugenic sterilization it waited until
1920 for 17 years after Indiana would
put it in the center of the legal battle
was that Virginia hospitals decided they
didn't want to sterilize anyone until
their law was tested in the courts all
the way up to the Supreme Court to
accomplish this they decided to create a
test case it was Cary bucks misfortune
to be at the wrong place at the wrong
time
Carrie's story is a sad one and an
infuriating one she was being raised in
poverty by a single mother and was taken
in by a foster family there was nothing
wrong with her physically or mentally
but she was raped by a nephew of her
foster mother when she became pregnant
out of wedlock the family had her
declared epileptic and feeble-minded and
shipped her off to the state colony for
epileptics and feeble-minded she arrived
just when the colony superintendent was
looking for an inmate to put at the
center of his test case Carrie had just
the personal attributes the genisis were
looking for she had been designated
feeble-minded and as a woman who had
given birth out of wedlock at 17 she
embodied the eugenic nightmare of feeble
minded people reproducing rapidly and
flooding the nation with so-called
defectives Carrie also had the sort of
family the eugenicist wanted her mother
was also a colony inmate who had been
designated feeble-minded although likely
she was not and she had other relatives
in the institution which could help the
state establish a hereditary pattern
there was more to Carrie story but no
one was interested in hearing it she was
not in fact feeble-minded despite the
state's unreliable intelligence testing
her school records which the colony was
not interested in revealed her to be of
perfectly normal intelligence and she
was not epileptic she had never had a
seizure and never would the colony held
a hearing on whether Carrie should be
sterilized a proceeding heavily stacked
against her rule that it should that she
should be and it was this order that was
appealed through the Virginia courts all
the way up to the US Supreme Court
nations rely on civil society public and
private institutions devoted to higher
values to promote truth and justice and
keep them on the right path four of the
nation's most respected professions were
involved in Carrie bucks case medicine
academia law and the judiciary in the
form of four powerful men each of them
was on the wrong side dr. Albert pretty
was the man who selected Carrie to be
the first person operated on under
Virginia's law he was a physician who
served as superintendent of the colony
for epileptics and feeble-minded he'd
also been one of the main people who
lobbied the legislature to pass the
eugenic sterilization law in his
campaign for eugenic sterilization dr.
pretty had much of the medical
profession behind him across the country
doctors took a leading role in promoting
eugenics and eugenic sterilization
journals were filled with polemical
articles advocating sterilization who
titles like race suicide for social
parasites Harry Laughlin the head of the
eugenics Record Office in Long Island
New York was the scientist who gave his
expert opinion at the Virginia law
should be upheld and the Kerry should be
sterilized
Laughlin was the most prominent advocate
for eugenic sterilization and he had
drafted the model law of the states were
using to draw up their own laws
Laughlin who had a doctorate in biology
from Princeton and had been a professor
was also to a great extent
representative of his academic peers
many of the nation's most prominent
academic scientists strongly supported
eugenics and eugenic sterilization the
center of this academic support few
Jetix I'm sorry to report was right here
at Harvard University President Charles
William Elliot addressed a 1912 meeting
of the Harvard Club of San Francisco
advocating for racial purity he wrote an
article supporting eugenic sterilization
and he served as vice-president of the
first international eugenics Congress in
London in 1912 and two leading Harvard
Jeannette geneticists were among the
nation's most influential scientific
advocates for eugenics finally or
thirdly Aubrey strode was the lawyer who
drafted the Virginia sterilization law
and he went on to defended in the courts
all the way up to the United States
Supreme Court strokes profession lawyers
also offered strong support for eugenics
among the influential voices praising
Connecticut's first-in-the-nation
eugenics law was the president of the
American Bar Association who declared
eugenic marriage laws necessary to
protect quote future generations from
the evil operation of the laws of
heredity finally it was the great Oliver
Wendell Holmes who had the last word on
carries fate and who with his broadside
against society's imbeciles lent his
enormous intellectual prestige the
sterilization caused Holmes was not a
man who easily found enjoyment but he
would later say that upholding
Virginia's eugenic sterilization law and
carry sterilization had given him real
pleasure of all the professions it was
the judiciary's role that was the most
disappointing it is worth noting that
the Supreme Court that heard Cary bucks
case had some of the leading lights of
American law on it the Chief Justice was
William Howard Taft who had already
served as president it included Louis
Brandeis the great progressive who was
known
the people's attorney before joining the
court and of course there was Holmes
former harvard law professor and perhaps
the most respected justice in Supreme
Court history when the case reached
these nine great men they got the facts
wrong the legal analysis they applied
was shoddy and the vote was not close
those who airbrush buck V Bell from
history would likely offer a simple
explanation that is that it is an
anomaly the Supreme Court they would say
was briefly caught up in eugenics but it
was a short-lived one-time mistake and
the issues it raises are ones the
nation's long the nation long ago put
behind it but this argument has serious
flaws first unlike so many of the courts
worst rulings buck V Bell has never been
overruled in a 1942 case the Court
struck down an Oklahoma law providing
for sterilization of certain criminals
but it did so on very narrow grounds the
court expressly chose not to overturn or
even limit buck V Bell and after the
ruling states continued to sterilize
thousands of people as recently as 2001
a US Supreme Court of Appeals in
Missouri just one step below the Supreme
Court cited buck V Bell in ruling on the
case of a mildly [ __ ] woman ordered
by the state to be sterilized second
there's nothing outdated about the cases
subject matter as recently as 1983
Oregon's board of eugenics was still
functioning and it performed its last
sterilization in 1981 in 2014
investigative reporters discovered that
a hundred and fifty female prisoners in
California had been sterilized between
2006 and 2010 not always with the
woman's consent and other examples of
eugenic sterilization done unofficially
emerge with disturbing regularity more
broadly the 21st century is being hailed
as the century of biology an era that
experts say will be defined by the new
biology of genomic research including a
vastly deeper understanding of the
genetic blueprint for individual humans
scientists are now able to edit human
embryos paving the way for what the
press has dubbed designer babies this
will make it far easier for the state to
impose eugenics if it chooses a final
reason buck V Bell remains critically
important is that its deepest subject is
a timeless one power and how those who
have it
use it against those who do not carry
was at the bottom of the nation's
economic and social hierarchies in her
plea to the court she was asking for
protection from powerful people and
institutions that threatened to do her
harm throughout the history of American
law that has not been a good position to
be in the code of hammurabi the ancient
Babylonian law that French
archaeologists uncovered in 1902
included two hundred and eighty two
distinct laws covering such modern
seeming doctrines as liability for
negligent acts and the presumption of
innocence the code also had an eloquent
statement of its own purpose to bring
about the rule of righteousness in the
land so that the strong should not harm
the weak that simple ideal remains more
than 3500 years later the laws highest
calling but it is a vision that the
American legal system has all too often
failed to live up to Dred Scott Homer
Plessy Fred Korematsu they were all
weaker parties unjustly harmed by
stronger ones who came to the Supreme
Court seeking justice in each case the
court sided with the strong in fact
American laws tendency to favor the
powerful could be said to be one of its
defining features in the end this is the
most troubling thing about buck V Bell
it presented the court with a stark
choice between Hammurabi's ideal and its
precise opposite the ancient principle
of justice teaches that the purpose of
law is to ensure that the strong do not
harm the weak the eugenicist and the
state of Virginia insisted that the
strong must harm the weak and that it
was the law's duty to help faced with
this decision the Supreme Court did not
merely side with the strong it
enthusiastically urged them on insist it
insisted it be better for all the world
if society strongest members simply
finished off people like Kerry once and
for all even the ancient Babylonians
understood that helping the strong to
obliterate the weak is the very opposite
of justice
so I think we'd like to take questions
comments well listening to what you said
it's really quite interesting
unfortunately for me it made me feel
uncomfortable about it because I'd been
an obstetrician for 40 years and I've
done abortions and one of the main
reasons we had done abortions was to
eradicate trisomy 21 [ __ ] ISM and
it sounds as if we applied the principle
of the weak shouldn't be hurt badly by
the strong I feel uncomfortable about
the what I might have done I think it's
a I think it's very interesting point um
and you know obviously there's a lot of
nuance here right and you could say one
level of eugenics that is certainly very
disturbing is the kind that Carrie buck
experienced where the state imposed it
on her as a potential parent the state
made the decision that she could not
reproduce and that is invasive in a very
high level it sounds like maybe you're
talking about a different case where the
parent has made the decision it's a very
common thing I mean in the sense that
eugenics the termination of pregnancies
is practiced all the time no but with
the consent of the parent right with the
consent of the parent but not know the
fetus right no I so I'm just
distinguishing between those two cases
but I think you're right we this still
puts us in an area of eugenics that some
people may not feel comfortable with um
and I wonder if other people have have
thoughts about it
yeah there's been a number of different
journalists recently who have been
talking about the rise of American
authoritarianism and I'm just wondering
how you kind of viewed this conversation
within the current movement of Donald
Trump and the direction towards
basically people feeling socially
threatened in as far as the mores of our
society and the movement in that area
and how that makes them react in a very
protectionist and overbearingly
authoritarian way towards those who are
not in power and that's a great point
and we could definitely draw a lot of
parallels between the 1920s and today I
think I alluded to some of them that it
was a time of great transition also a
time of very high levels of immigration
the eugenicist were very scared of the
new immigrants who often were of a
different religion and look different
and a lot of the people who were most
active in the eugenic movement were the
the middle class the upper class white
Protestants who felt that their world
was slipping away from them and I think
you're right that you can see eugenics
as a form of authoritarianism another
parallel is I didn't go into it and
suchlike but in the book I talk a lot
about Oliver Wendell Holmes and the
degree to which he had a very
authoritarian upbringing and then
judicial philosophy he was a member of
the Boston Brahmin class here in Boston
and in fact his father dr. Oliver
Wendell Holmes senior who was the Dean
of Harvard Medical School coined that
phrase Boston Brahmin and if you think
about it that was very intentionally
saying that the quote old and and and
higher families of Boston were a caste
of their own like the Brahmin caste in
India and of course under Hinduism
they're the the the Brahmins were
thought to be endowed by God so that was
the way in which Holmes was brought up
he was brought up to think that his
people and the Oliver's the Wendell's
and the homes were all Boston Brahmin
Brahmin families homes his first
relative ancestor attended Harvard in
the 1600s he was raised to believe that
his people were better and that he was
at
top of a hierarchy and when Carrie buck
comes to the Supreme Court and she's
from the lowest social class in the
south the lowest white social class poor
white you know sometimes it's called
trash but you know obviously that's not
an accepted way to refer them but that
low social economic class of whites
that's who Kerry bucks people are and
what Holmes looks at that he sees the
very bottom of the hierarchy and he
thinks it should be obliterated so
that's another form of authoritarianism
but I think that you're right it's all
about power and control I think we see
more of it when people are threatened
and I think there's a reason the 1920s
speak to you know 2016 having some
states like North Carolina done
reparations yes absolutely yes laws have
been repealed and there have been
reparations it's just the Supreme Court
hasn't said that this holding which says
that the state has the power to
sterilize people for eugenic reasons and
that that doesn't present constitutional
problems as long as there's a due
process hearing and the state has you
know a legitimate reason to do it that
legal authority is still there so the
concern would be what if you know and
who knows what direction our country is
going into with the next president and
the next Congress if we get to a point
in a few years where either Congress or
the states begin to think about eugenics
the the default law from the Supreme
Court is still buck vs. Bell authorizing
it so that's the concern at the time of
these events the the culture was
saturated with eugenics and with you
Genesis however when the Supreme Court
makes rulings today of course as we know
with citizens united and other rulings
there's a lot of reaction from the pop
from the population and from the press
was there any reaction to this ruling
when Oliver
Holmes made it there was and you know
you're right to say that eugenics
permeated the culture and you know the
reaction was largely positive and as I
said I mean so true you know thought
leaders as the president of Harvard
University was saying that eugenics was
a good thing Theodore Roosevelt was
saying that eugenics was a good thing
and the press was in that camp as well
so you know it was injured to read
articles in the New York Times before
1927 just you know with happy reports
about eugenic activities and isn't it
great that this new eugenic group has
you know risen up and is counseling
people on who to marry and teaching
about eugenics the press coverage was
very positive leading up to buck V Bell
and then the reaction afterward that
wasn't largely positive there were some
editorials and articles that were more
skeptical but overwhelmingly positive
interestingly the one group that was
opposed to eugenics all the way through
was the Catholic Church and they are
really in many ways the heroes of this
story when legislators met to consider
eugenic sterilization laws you know I
think professors would be very trouble
to realize that the sort of people who
are going there to lobby for it were
literally the League of Women Voters was
a very big supporter and the people that
opposed it were often priests and nuns
and people active in the Catholic Church
and it was for a couple of reasons one
is the concern about reproduction and
just as many Catholics you know as
Catholics oppose abortion they were
concerned about that but also the
Catholic view was that people should be
evaluated on their soul on their spirit
and the Catholic Church wasn't
comfortable with this eugenic movement
that said we're gonna look at all these
individual traits and decide whether
people are you know fit or not fit
worthy or not worthy so those were the
you know it was the Catholic
publications that also spoke out against
the ruling when it came down so you know
I think we have to credit the role of
the church there as being right on
something when the rest of the country
was was wrong
yeah in terms of wolf a comment and a
question
I mentioned the Catholic Church but as
far as eugenics could be looked at in
terms of what happened in terms of
during slavery with Catholic Church from
running slavery because blacks had no
souls right we could also look at Gabino
in France as one concession from the
fathers of the eugenic movement that led
to the United States back to Germany and
then back to the US again we could look
at what happened to Puerto Rican women
were sterilized because of immigration
in 1960s the Tuskegee experiments and so
forth recent case Haitian immigrants the
chrome camp in Miami were a man who grew
breasts and women could that reproduce
because once you have a children a child
born in the u.s. automatically get
citizenship so my question is in terms
of almost every society has a form of
Technology of control and then the
political economy of civilization so to
what extent I mean as far as the whole
sort of moral fabric of law and so forth
is concerned out to what extent do we
simply allow this technology of control
for the sake of security and the various
name no I think that's a very very good
point if you'll allow me I wanted to say
a bit about race which I hadn't said yet
um you're absolutely right that in more
recent years eugenics has been used a
lot against african-americans and
Latinos and others but what was really
so perverse about eugenics akari bucks
time is some people you know are
surprised to learn that Carrie buck was
white and you know the reason she was
being sterilized was in Virginia at the
time that the very same day that
Virginia adopted its eugenic
sterilization law it adopted a second
law which raised the penalties for
interracial marriage interracial sex and
adopted the one drop of blood rule to
really put a strong wall between black
and white races and the you Genesis had
they were so racist that they had given
up on the black race they did not think
that it was worth trying to uplift the
black race they did not think that was
possible so at that time the Jaxx
movement was all about lifting up the
white race and also making sure that the
black race did not intermingle with it
so it was a level of racist that was so
extreme that they weren't even focusing
on sterilizing black people because they
thought there was no point and it was
people like Carrie buck from the lower
echelon of the white race they were
really troubled about because they
wanted to lift up the white race and
they saw Carrie's class as the the white
people who are bringing it down so
interesting I think the question might
partially really humble questions
I think I'm curious to understand on
what basis did these individuals at the
time single out certain groups for
example Jewish people or Italian
immigrants people from southern European
countries it was it data that they were
looking at patterns behavior I think
social patterns I think is just trying
to understand no it's a great question
and I think there's a bit of a chicken
and egg thing here that I think that you
know a lot of these guys did not like
these groups and then created data to
show that they were inferior I mean
there was a real visceral just hatred of
you know of Jews and Italians and Asians
and it was a guy named Madison Grant who
was a very popular writer at the time he
wrote a book that was a best-seller
called the passing of a great race which
actually anticipated a lot of Nazi ideas
about Arianism and the way Madison Grant
who was an upper-class New Yorker who
went to Columbia Law School and was on
the board of the Museum of Natural
History the way he spoke about the
Polish Jews that were walking down the
street in New York and in their Polish
Jewish clothing and they were trying to
they were gonna marry American women it
would there was so much hatred that I
think that they created data then to
show that these groups were inferior so
that was the racial thing but it's also
very interesting how they chose the
individual groups of
of you know regular old stock Americans
who should be sterilized and there were
these categories the disabled the Deaf
the blind and and it was a guy named
Harry Laughlin who's one of the real
villains of my book who ran the eugenics
Record Office who drew up a lot of the
categories drew up the model statute
that many states used to draw up their
own laws and one interesting aspect of
this is he included on his list of the
people who should not be allowed to
reproduce because they were unworthy
epileptics and it turns out Harry
Laughlin was epileptic and it's unclear
exactly when he knew that he was
epileptic he and his wife never had
children but reading that one does
wonder you know so much of hatred starts
in self hatred was he so driven to
eugenics in part because he felt that he
was unworthy and and even when he had
his first seizures and everyone knew he
was epileptic at a certain point his
wife wouldn't let him drive anymore
he never argued to remove epileptics
from the list of people unworthy to
reproduce so there's just a lot mixed up
in this bag yeah the Darwin have any
role yes so the man who invented
eugenics who coined the term from the
two Greek words for good in birth
Francis Galton was a half cousin of
Darwin's and he was really thinking in
the moment right after Darwin was coming
up with his theories of evolution and
Galton's talked about how we can see how
nature works itself out through survival
of the fittest and and and that natural
process but Dalton argued that what his
half cousin was writing about at McCrae
naturally the genesis could speed up and
do more humanely rather than you know
let everyone fight it out over years and
years and years yeah do the right
choosing and sort of you know design the
the fittest would would survive but you
know Darwin himself was not a eugenicist
and he wrote some actually rather
eloquent passages where he said that we
could choose the people who we think are
the weak
and the most unworthy to live but if we
did that and we obliterated them we
would also be obliterated our own
humanity so it's really interesting that
Darwin was a great enough man that he
understood that this is not how his idea
should be used I wonder if you can try
to predict the future a little bit in
terms of genetics and non like the
science of genetics and non-invasive
prenatal testing and you know if you if
you have any sense of what laws might be
passed and also the coming together of
possibly strange bedfellows in terms of
you know like liberal disability rights
activists and then conservatives who may
be anti-abortion in all cases so if you
can just talk about that yeah sure it's
a great question and there are so many
aspects to it I won't be able to do it
justice but one thing a lot of people
are focusing on right now is that the
news emerge quite recently that in China
they have succeeded in editing the human
embryo right so that is the first
creation of what they call designer
babies where they can go in and actually
edit out some of the genes rearrange
them and create a baby that has been
genetically designed and those changes
will then be carried on to future
generations so there's a big big
discussion going on internationally now
about whether this should be allowed a
lot of people are saying you know dr.
Frankenstein and these are changes that
will forever change humanity but this is
gonna happen and in England they just
approved a researcher there to do
editing of a human embryo so then we
have the question you know how do we
feel about this does this feel like
Harry buck and I feel you know it's
interesting when there was a hearing
recently in Washington about what to do
ethically about editing of human genomes
one of the people who testified was a
mother whose baby had died at the age of
six days from genetically carry disease
and she was weeping and she said you
know just friggin do it allow this
because if she had been
able to edit out the genes from her baby
her baby would have lived and in this
discussion you now see that some of the
people who are most in favor of allowing
the human embryos to be edited are
people who themselves carry these
genetic markers so there's a scientist
in Washington whose mother you know
contracted a you know a terrible genetic
disease and and went mad and he may have
that same disease he would like his
children not to have it so he's saying
we should allow this so it becomes an
interesting twist where it's actually
the quote week the people who are
genetically you know unfit who are
saying let us use this you know somewhat
eugenic procedure to make ourselves
stronger and make the next generation
stronger so um I actually think that in
many ways you know we may want to flip
some of our thinking about eugenics and
see that when we can start editing
things maybe will be a way to actually
help the quote weak rather than to
oppress them so I think that's one of
many issues that's gonna be out there
yeah oh oh yeah so the one in Virginia
was just outside Lynchburg Virginia they
believed back then in putting epileptics
and feeble-minded people out in the
country because they thought that
working in the fields and getting fresh
air would help them to be cured although
no one was ever cured and this colony
system was you know there were other
colonies throughout the country it was
it was a you know one of these waves of
reform it was thought to be a good thing
but you know people like Kerry buck and
her mother were sent there for you know
possibly for life Kerry buck they let
her leave the colony after she was
sterilized because the thinking was she
was no longer a threat to humanity she
wasn't gonna reproduce Kerry's mother
lived her whole life in this colony and
it's you know so these were you know sad
places where people were trapped they
called them patients but they were
inmates yeah I know we've heard about
prisons where they tested medication on
people and and the inmates were not
aware that this was being done in a
their consent how much of a voice did
she have in these proceedings I mean was
she completely informed of what was
going on and did she have a lawyer who
was able to argue in her in her behalf I
mean the whole thing is so said and you
know it's interesting cuz a reporter in
Virginia asked me today if if you could
talk to Carrie buck what would you ask
her and I think it was this very thing I
said I wish I knew at every stage in the
process what she knew we know that at
her her sterilization hearing that was
held at the colony she was represented
by a guardian cuz the law required that
but we don't know what she knew the
guardian wasn't doing much to protect
her she was very quickly ordered to be
sterilized there's one poignant line the
transcript exists and you can read all
the arguments there's one poignant line
where this Audrey strobe the lawyer
who's trying to sterilize her
transferred the end and says you know
does she have anything to say and she
says you know that she trusts four
people it's not clear who her people are
is there a person The Guardian that is
actually working for the people trying
to sterilize her then when they actually
go up further in the court system the
Guardian gets her a lawyer because
that's required under the the statute
well the lawyer that they get her had
been the chairman of the board of the
colony he was friends with all the
lawyers on the other side and he wanted
her sterilized and he wrote some
terrible briefs which do you know
they're much shorter than the briefs for
the other side they leave out a lot of
important cases and you'll be reading
when you realize Wow this last page and
a half really that's all reason she
should be sterilized you know so this is
what she had and you know I think at
some point you know with the going to
the Supreme Court she didn't realize
what was having to the more really the
more tragic stories her sister Doris who
was her younger sister also in the
colony for epileptics and feeble-minded
after Carrie buck is sterilized after
the 1927 ruling Doris is sterilized
right after and she's not told what is
done to her they tell her that she's
having an appendectomy or something like
that and many years later when Carrie
buck and and her sister are located by
by the the then head of the colony many
many years later in 70s who's you know
good guy doesn't doesn't agree what was
on the 20s she first finds out what was
done to her and she and her husband who
were told the news began weeping and
they say you know we spent her whole
lives trying to get pregnant and you
know we go to the doctor and they
mentioned you know the doctor mentioned
that Doris had a scar and you know she
thought was an appendectomy so she
learned as an old woman what had been
done to her and this was not uncommon
but you know unfortunately because we
don't really have oral histories and
journals we don't know who found out
when but many many women were never told
you know and maybe died not knowing what
the state had done to them that's very
sad yeah so the culture of Medicine
until relatively recently was that
doctors told patients what to do on
patient's complied with the doctor's
orders so when did inform consent become
something in the practice of medicine
that the patients were supposed to can
understand what was being done to them
and consent to it you know it was just
starting around this era before you know
while while buck V Bell was working its
way through the system and there was a
case in New York State where the Court
of Appeals the highest court in New York
ruled very strongly that patients had a
right to be informed in the operating on
them without getting their consent was
almost a form of assault so it was just
beginning to happen and there was a
little concern about that they were
worried that you know that could if that
you know doctrine began to spread more
broadly it could be an imposition but it
was really after after buck V Bell that
it became you know much more common
because you're right I mean if that had
been a robust a doctrine at the time
certainly it was being you know floated
right and left by the Genesis by eugenic
sterilization significant percentage
when you're dealing with that larger
population you're gonna have failures
yeah I have not heard of any examples of
that I mean I'm sure was going on you
know they had all kinds of nefarious
ways of dealing and everything
you know what what happened to carry his
baby right they you know Kari is
pregnant when she's ordered to be you
know sent to the colony for epileptics
and feeble-minded you know her her
foster family just wants her to go
doctor pretty says you know we don't
accept any pregnant women we don't
accept any children so actually you know
they yet put her in with some other
family until she gives birth and then
there's a question about what to do with
her baby well lo and behold they decide
to give it to the foster family who
raised her baby as their own and then
they don't let Carrie buck come back and
join them later so um you know I think
babies were being passed around and you
know all kinds of you know things were
worked out but I'm sure it was all done
in a terrible way for the individuals
involved yeah so the vote was 8 to 1 on
the court what was the dissent so yes
great question um there was no dissent
but the the the one justice who voted
against was the one Catholic on the
court and the most conservative member
of the court and there have been some
Catholic you know law journals that have
written about you know the the silence
of the dissent what would he have said
what was and and it's hard to know he
was very cranky justice he sometimes he
just objected to government activities
of various kinds there were a lot of
cases where he just didn't like the
government mucking people's lives but he
was also a very religious Catholic and
the thought is that he probably objected
on moral ground spiritual grounds but
just didn't say but we really wonder
what all these justices were thinking
and you know for me one of the big
questions was what was Louis Brandeis
thinking right I mean this is you know
he was known as the people's attorney
when he practiced law right around here
he was the great champion of the
dispossessed and he just signs on right
so early on in this process I was very
excited to learn that a lot professor
just written a 900-page biography of
Louis Brandeis and I ordered it because
I wanted to see what someone who had
looked at his entire life said and once
again we see the theme buck V Bell was
mentioned in a footnote in that in that
book there was so much about his
involvement in Internet
Zionism his childhood in Louisville and
all that and then footnote saying of
course he was in the majority in buck V
Bell as far as I could tell you know
Brandeis had said in an interview one
point that sometimes he just voted with
the majority to kind of you know be
convivial you know so-so and and the
Chief Justice at the time Taft was very
big on building he liked to have
unanimity or close to unanimity so the
dynamic may have been that Brandeis you
know just kind of let Taft twist his arm
but it's just amazing to me that no
one's really explained that you know so
there are a lot of you know silences in
this case which you know maybe will
never be filled in the 27 ruling carry
buck sterilization and the 1947 willow
book mental institution in Staten Island
which was the biggest state-run mental
institution in the United States which
closed in 1987 and you said I think I
believe you said the 1981 with elastic
civilization right and they closed in
1987 does your book make that connection
it doesn't it just kind of it doesn't
get that far into the future but you
know the Willowbrook case you know is
something that you know I'm from New
York and it's something we all yeah okay
great so you know that we all wrestle
with this because what was going on in
Willowbrook you know when it was open
felt like the 1920s the way in which the
inmates were you know horribly
mistreated and shut away and and so
forth but and the ACLU you know
to its credit you know stop that but the
critique now is that no other system was
put in place what we have now in New
York is we don't have Willowbrook but
you know do we have a humane system you
know for taking care of folks you know I
think that's a national problem but but
I don't and I guess in part because I
wasn't aware that you know sterilization
occurred there but you know the the
larger problem of how we deal with
people who are you know
developmentally disabled in every ways
is just huge and I think you know not
enough attention is given to it as a
policy matter not enough attention is
given to it as you know writers and
readers I think we just we we should be
learning and thinking more about it what
happened to Kerry's daughter and whether
she ever found out about her mother well
you know you know sometimes when I talk
to people about this story they're like
oh you know what what's the happy part
of it and I say like there really
there's there are no heroes and there's
no happy part of it so that's a good
lead-in to my answer to your question
here which is that Vivian buck died at
at the age of of six of something like
measles and so she never learned any of
this but she did have a little bit of a
school record at the time and right
before the initial trial these horrible
you genisys who were putting together
the case sent an expert from the
eugenics Record Office to examine this
then infant and he was able to swear
that she was mentally defective because
compared to the other baby that she was
next to she seemed to smile less or
react differently so so that was enough
to say that you know and then Holmes
turns into three generations of
imbeciles
so she was recorded as being you know
imbecilic by the Supreme Court in fact
she was you know a very bright and you
know a perfectly normal child and you
know another the you know hundreds of
villains in my book the foster mother
who takes you know who throws carryout
gets her committed because she's been
raped by her nephew then takes her baby
when they go to talk to her after the
baby has died you know she does say
there was nothing wrong with Vivian you
know she was she was fine
so yeah just sadness every direction you
look including that one
yeah language I know that there are some
writers and poets in here you're using
the word gene-editing
I mean of course it sounds beautiful
right we all would have to have editors
to meet something to know beautiful what
if we had used the term gene
manipulation gene hacking or gene
splicing what sort of the outcomes of
the way in which we're thinking about
gene editing be the same I think it's a
great question and you know this is very
much a live issue right now so we're
gonna have to decide what work to use
and you're right people using the word
editing but maybe we should push back
against that or maybe we shouldn't and
maybe we should say that if you want
your genes edited so that your child
doesn't inherit some bad trade in your
own genes maybe it is like editing but
if I could just since we're talking bout
language one other way language really
figures in this is this word imbeciles
and three generations of imbeciles are
enough you know there are a million
things wrong with this decision the fact
the facts are all wrong it's barbaric it
ignores the law everything else but one
rather pedantic point but that bothers
me is that there were actually three
very definite categories of mental
defect back then very precise idiots
were at the bottom then imbeciles were
in the middle and morons were at the top
and these were registered I found a
pamphlet from the US Department of Labor
I think that had a nice little chart
these were well known categories Carrie
buck and her mother you know who were
probably just perfectly normal had been
labeled morons when they got to the
colony for applicants and feeble-minded
you know it's not not a great category
but it is one notch above imbeciles so
in addition to everything else Oliver
Wendell Holmes does he he did motes them
in its decision he calls them imbeciles
which they you know the record made
clear no they were you know in carries
case mid-level [ __ ] and in her mother's
case a low-level [ __ ] but they were not
imbeciles so you know Holmes was a great
epic grammas and a great wordsmith and
you know one reason I use the word
imbeciles for the title I mean they're
several including the bigger question of
who are the imbeciles you know I would
say not the people being sterilized with
the people doing the sterilizing but but
also it's just such a resonant word and
Holmes's choice of it and one thing I
loved my publisher did is you know they
sent me a picture of the cover they had
come up with for the book and they've
got great designers who do this and what
they did I thought it was so brilliant
was they turned the word imbeciles you
some of you may have it and see into a
dictionary definition and they put in
the syllabus syllable ization and I
thought that was so right because it's
really saying let's interrogate the word
imbeciles you know who are the imbeciles
Wyden Holmes choose the word imbeciles
and so that kind of nomenclature is
everywhere and it's definitely part of
Holmes's bag of tricks and used to you
know malignant purposes yeah it's really
appropriate because of the way the the
coats in the in the genetics are there
Arendt
you read the stream of so when you use
the word editing it works out as if it
were an editor and also as a journalist
you may have a very benign view of the
word editing but any journalist who gets
edited feels that the editor is evil and
is out to crush their soul so you may
think it's a nice thing to me editing
makes my skin crawl
oh yeah ya know the outcome is terrible
they take that beautiful thing you wrote
and it's become some horrible thing they
wanted you to write so I you know it's
in the by of the beholder I think yeah
okay yeah yeah say that parts of this
conversation reminded me about what was
done to the Aborigines in Australia
because they certainly wanted to get rid
of them that they chose a more humane
way of permitting intermarriage rather
than incarcerate in the end member I
mean it's you know again you know
depressing stories you know here they
are so yes I think one other depressing
part of this is how we see the same
tropes over and over again right we see
that the way we treated you know our
african-americans are lower caste whites
very similar to how indigenous
populations were treated other places
and then of course you know one of the
horrors of the you know many ARMs of the
story is seeing just how closely what we
were doing
came to Nazi Germany right I mean the
Nazis very happily adopted what we were
doing because we were doing what they
were about to do we had designated
Aryans as being superior Madison grant
wrote a whole book about it
we were then you know sterilizing people
something they were happy to do so if
the line between America and Nazi
Germany was as thin as it was I think
you're right
we're gonna see the same thing with
Australia we're gonna see it everywhere
because you know there are only so many
different ways that people are horrible
to other people it often falls into
certain patterns is there one word yeah
last question it would seem that all of
the bundles home legacy has had a very
good public relations team preserving
his relatively positive a very closet of
reputation whereas in addition to Yarra
fabulous book and in the magazine
article and the current Hobbit which is
excellent they've been the life and
times of all of the one Dolan 2001 and
Edward black Edwin black book 2003 so
it's not as if you are the first to
point out some of these wishes in his
reputation so what what do you attribute
to Elizabeth and then attorney 'then
it's a great question and you know
they're actually what it was a very
organised PR operation during his
lifetime there was a an article called
the house that built homes and it was a
house on Dupont Circle in Washington DC
where a lot of journalists live and
homes would have dinner there all the
time and they would prop up his
reputation even back then they'd write
glowing things about him in the New
Republic in other places walter lippmann
the the leading journalistic commentator
of the time was part of that group so he
had a PR organ at the time and then it's
been carried through yes he gets amazing
press we hear about how you know as a
Harvard student he volunteered god bless
him to fight in the Civil War and was
you know wounded in battle three times
we hear the the heroic stuff we don't
hear about some of his terrible
decisions that go well beyond this his
racial decisions are horrible
he wrote a decision
rejecting an attempt by blacks in
Alabama to vote that was so terrible
that it not only stopped these blacks
from voting but it has been a just an
albatross around the necks of voting
right cases for generations and
generations saying that it's a political
question the court can't get involved
there's so many terrible things he's
done he is I think well regarded by his
alma mater I know when I was over there
there were many portraits of them
everywhere you looked and you know
someone asked me you know what my goals
were with this book and this isn't the
highest goal but I did say one thing I'd
like to do would be really to pull homes
down off of his pedestal and kind of
enlighten people to what a terrible guy
he was in many ways so by asking that
question I think you know you're helping
with the cause so I think that's it
[Applause]
thank you all again for coming as I
mentioned the book is for sale at their
registers and will form the signing
lineup this middle aisle will get the
chairs out of the way as quickly as
possible thank you
that's